what up reject nation it's your girl sally aka
sally lamonico aka salamander now you can only
call me salamander if you subscribe you know we
gotta be on a nickname basis so uh please hit
that subscribe button it's completely free i mean
in this economy with inflation like why wouldn't
you just like have something for free you know
so if this is your first time watching one of my
videos on this channel i'm doing a marvel movie
marathon where i go through all of the marvel
movies starting with phase one all the way through
phase four because i have not seen most of them i
know shocking listen time just got away from me
i i guess you can check out my previous videos i
started with iron man and today we are continuing
with iron man 2. this is super exciting if you
enjoyed this video please give it a like it really
does help the algorithm it helps us out a lot it's
like free tipping like you're tipping out but like
it's free just give it a like you know what i mean
if you would also like to watch my full reaction
it is on their patreon if you go to patreon.com
the real rejects you can watch my full reaction
and you can even watch more of greg and john
which i know you want to because they're great
guys they got a lot of full reactions on there
tv shows movies that aren't on their channel
you can also follow me if you want at selling
the monaco on instagram and like i have a youtube
channel so it'd be cool if you like subscribe to
that too and lastly thanks to prepper for editing
together the highlights for this video i'm very
appreciative greg and john are very appreciative
thank you so much guys now let iron man 2 commence
we had that vodka ready
same
i can't tell if you had highlights or just gray
hair perfectly perfect strands of gray hair
it's the fourth of july wait that's sick
oh my god
there was just one guy in the audience that
was just like and all the girls were screaming
what does pepper potts think about that
and now making a special guest appearance
from the great beyond to tell you what it's
all about please welcome my father howard
everything is achievable through technology
better living it reminds me of walt disney
with the music look it's disneyland i'm kidding
this is larry hey the oracle of oracle what
a pleasure and i see it larry king larry
was that stan that was stanley to turn over
the iron man suit would be to turn over myself
which is tantamount to indentured servitude or
prostitution depending on what state you're in you
can't have it look i'm no expert in prostitution
of course not you're a senator come on
oh ah this is a disney movie let the record
reflect that i observed mr hammer entering
the chamber and i am wondering if and when
any actual expert will also be in attendance
i'm no expert i'd defer to you
anthony uh senator if i may
he called him anthony you know we live in a
world of grave threats threats that mr stark
will not always be able to foresee okay
i wish that would happen in real life not
the robots killing people but if there was
a hearing and that happened that would be funny
all right america is secure you want my property
you can't have it but i did you a big favor
i have successfully privatized world peace
i tried to play ball with these
ass clowns thank you mr stark
you buddy oh my god if court hearings went
like that life would be pretty interesting
one thing i've proven is that you
can count on me to pleasure myself
bob the builder can he fix it
wake up daddy's home welcome home sir
congratulations on the opening ceremonies it
was such a success this was your seventh hearing
and may i say how refreshing it is to finally see
oh my gosh old school youtube you are running out
of both time and options unfortunately the device
that's keeping you alive is also killing you matt
what are you thinking what what are you thinking
hey i'm thinking i'm busy and you're angry about
something the expo is a gigantic waste of time
i need to wear a surgical mask until you're
feeling better is that okay that's rude
cut to 20 20. yeah pepperoni i'm trying
to run the company stop trying to do it
and do it i'm not asking you to try
to do it i'm asking you to physically
do it i need you to do it i am trying to you're
not listening to me i'm trying to make your ceo
i hereby irrevocably appoint you chairman and
ceo of stark industries effective immediately
mom i thought there'd be a legal issue but
actually i'm uh capable of appointing my
successor my successor being you take it just
take it i don't know what's the thing don't
think drink oh the way her eyes lit up girl
yeah get that bread and that robert johnny jrd
i just want to know what his beef is
i promise you this is the only time i
will ask you to sign over your company
what's your name lady rushman natalie rushman
front and center coming to the church i need
her she's got everything that i rule number
one never take your eye off your opponent
oh my god get it bro will that be
all mr stark yes that will be all
she's like get out girl you're
a competition i want one no
is he like extra objectifying in this movie mr
musk how are you congratulations on the promotion
thank you very much those merlin answers are
fantastic thank you yeah good idea for an electric
jet that's elon musk better actor than amber heard
christine everherd from vanity fair you guys know
hi yes yes yes roughly btw big story the new
ceo of stark industry he's like i [__] her
yikes this cannot happen absolutely
i understand how can i help you
where's happy he's waiting outside
okay get him i need help right away
so did he just like kick out one
of the drivers like how did he
what
that's messed up
hang on
y'all what is this what oh my god
how is security not just like
well i yeah why would they
kind of broke his neck
oh
hopscotch jump rope i wonder if
he can double dutch with those
okay someone else could have done that oh my god
oh my god why they keep
showing it that's horrific bro
she's gonna need therapy
how is he still alive
you're gonna get electrocuted
now they come right actually that's pretty
accurate i don't get a little fine-tuning
you could have made a solid paycheck you could
have sold it to north you come from uh family of
thieves and butchers you try
to rewrite your own history
white people if you can make god bleed then
people will cease to believe and they will be
blood in the water hey tony before you go
palladium in the chest painful way to die
i don't want to go home we're in
europe let's go to venice cipriani
remember oh yeah company retreat a retreat during
a time like this well i'm just needing to recharge
your batteries and figure it all out not everybody
runs on batteries don't we that was a good line
what that absolute pleasure my name is justin
hammer i'd like to do some business with you
dig in what do we have today jack um we
have some salmon salmon so what he's like
the only difference between you and i is
that i have resources you need my resources
do you speak english because i can get a
translator very good man very good man very cool
i want my board you want a bird
is this a bird back in russia fundamentals of
the company are still very very strong pepper
pots drinking dr pepper anton vanko was a soviet
physicist who defected to the united states in
1963 his son ivan who is also a physicist was
convicted of selling soviet era weapons great
plutonium to pakistan you all right yeah i should
get to my desk you had this in your body i want
to make iron man look like an antique i want to
go to that stark expo i want to take a dump in
tony's front yard you know what i'm talking
about i could do that if this was your last
birthday party you're ever gonna have how would
you celebrate it i'll do whatever i wanted to do
sir i personally guarantee that within
24 hours iron man will be back on watch
i don't know what to do you gotta be kidding me
thank you so much tony we all
thank you so much for such a
wonderful night and we're gonna stay good keep
touching our butt oh my god what is happening
the party's over then again the party was
over for me like an hour and a half ago
the after party starts in 15 minutes if
anybody trevor doesn't like it there's the door
oh what my god
oh so this is where his friend is like enough
bro i'm only gonna say this once get out
you don't deserve to wear one of these shut
it down give me a fat beat to beat my voice
what is this script
put your hand down you think you
got what it takes to wear that suit
put it down you gonna take a shot put it down
they could have killed each other oh my god
major let's take it inside the silver does look
pretty dope told you i don't want to join your
super secret boy band no no no yeah i i remember
you do everything yourself how's that working
out for you i'm sorry i don't want to get up from
the wrong foot do i look at the patch of the eye
where's the staff here that's not looking so
good you are not the center of my universe
i have bigger problems than you in the southwest
region to deal with get him oh god you're gonna
steal my kidney and sell it [__] that's
lithium dioxide it's gonna take the edge
off we're trying to get you back to work i've been
looking for a suitable replacement for
palladium i've tried every combination
every permutation of every known element well
i'm here to tell you you haven't tried them all
ivan what's this is that a helmet doesn't
look like a helmet to me drone better i
like you i got you the bird i'm you said no
problem but you also said you couldn't find
volunteers so he's helping you government
wants suits like iron man you understand
don't get too attached to
things i'm going to let go
this order get descended off my ass it's
functional fully mission capable he was
cold he was calculating he never told me he loved
me and never even told me he liked me so it's a
little tough for me to digest when you're telling
me he said the whole future was riding on me and
he's passing it down i don't get that he was one
of the founding members of shield what i got a two
o'clock wait wait wait wait what's this you should
have led with that remember i got my eye on you
this face is this what i think it is yes it is
talking about firepower what are you talking to
the right guy this is a kinetic kill sidewinder
vehicle with a secondary cyclotrimethylene
trinitramine rdx burst it's completely elegant
it's bafflingly beautiful i call it the ex-wife
oh my god whoever wrote this particular script
doesn't like women very much i'm kidding
tony i built this for you i'm limited
by the technology of my time but one day
you'll figure this out and when you do you
will change the world my greatest creation
is you
and so sweet i thought i was coming to basically
apologize but i'm not oh you didn't come here to
apologize that goes without saying and i'm working
on that but i haven't been entirely uh up front
with you and i just want to try
to make good can i move this
what is it you're trying
to achieve sir new element
i heard you broke the perimeter uh yeah that
was like three years ago where you been you
know what this is exactly what i need to make
this work drop it drop it perfectly level
initializing prismatic accelerator
sir the reactor has accepted the modified
call what the hell does that mean ivan
this is not what we agreed to okay you
promised me suits and then you promised
this is not what i wanted what do you expect there
he is it's the birdman oh now you like the bird
you know what take the bird hey what'd the bird do
you give me suits that was our deal i don't know
if you're a genius or a fraud i don't know what
you are see these guys they're your babysitters
they are not to be trifled with he could easily
kill both of them incoming call with a blocked
number sir phone privilege just reinstated hey
tommy are you doing what you told me double
cycles more power yep what's up you want to run
some tests run them it tastes like coconut metal
but as revolutionary as this technology
there will always be a need for man
to be present that was so dumb why would he do
that because now they're all just gonna like
air force lieutenant colonel james rowe
yes king shut this down you got trouble
tony there are civilians present i'm here
on orders let's not do this right now
all these people are in danger we got to get him
out of here you got to trust me for the next five
minutes yeah i tried that i got tossed around your
house remember i think he's working with vancouver
he's a hacker you idiot you knew this
imagine imagine i'm locked on i
have target lock on what on you
bro
what's going on what's happening
the software's been overwritten
what what do you mean it's been overrated it's
impossible he's so stupid he'll kick his ass
i'm not taking you anywhere fine
you want me to drive no i'm driving
in the car why is everyone so mean
to the girls in this movie oh my god
no
nice work kid
and you just leave him there with the drone
she's kind of like a matured kim possible
make sure my tube can possible
jerome's is communicating in
its own unique language we'll choose one
and focus on that have you tried russian
yes queen have your moment so
we're about to get wet on this ride
wait wait wait wait
nice that's actually really cool he's gone
what are you doing i'm rebooting rudy's suit
oh my god
thank you very much agent romanov well done
with the new chess piece yes for the moment
i'm not dying what do you mean you're not
dying did you say you're dying is that you
i was going to tell you i didn't want to you
were going to tell me you really were dying
you didn't let it why didn't
you tell me that i was good
see that yeah yeah nice
jeez
get down
why didn't you just do that before that's your
guy here she's my place under arrest are you
kidding me behind your back sir i'm trying to
help no you suck you started to think like a
ceo taking out the competition i like that you
think you're making a problem for me i'm gonna
make a problem for you i'm gonna be seeing you
again real soon he's he's a villain but he's
not a very likable villain you coming with us
no i'm gonna stay till the park is clear okay
heads up you got one more drone incoming
this one looks different is it ivan
good to be back oh this ain't gonna be good
use the lasers oh i'm gonna
bust his bunker with the ex-wife
nice
you lose
all these drones are rigged to blow we
got to get out of here man all bombs
girl run don't just stare at it
honestly if they didn't have lights he could
have killed all of them oh my god i can't take
this anymore you can't i can't take this look
at me my body literally cannot handle the stress
i i quit i'm resigning that's it what what did
you just say you're done you don't have to make
any excuses you deserve better hmm thank you
for understanding yeah yeah let's let's talk
uh let's talk clean up i'll handle the transition
it'll be easy okay what about the press because
you only have the job for a week that's gonna
assume well with you it's like dog years i mean
it's like the president okay i think it was weird
you guys look like two seals fighting over a grape
i had just quit yes you don't have to do that i
i heard the whole thing you should get lost i was
here first get a roof agent romanov's assessment
of you personality overview mr stark displays
compulsive behavior prone to self-destructive
tendencies i was dying textbook narcissism
recruitment assessment for avenger initiative
iron man yes i got to think about it read on
tony stark not recommended how can you
approve me but not approve me rody and i
are being honored in washington it is my
honor oh my god distinguished awards to
lieutenant colonel james rhodes and mr tony
stark who is of course a national treasure
i love it
so i'm a ding dong dummy and i well first
of all gray didn't tell me to watch the
end credits but like i should have known
i knew there were end credits that i just
spaced this is a different setup
but i'm going to be watching the
end credits of iron man 2 right now
so let's fix my mistakes of the past
i see what they did there that's
exciting that just went right into uh
right into what was next so you'll be seeing
in my throat reaction i have the same outfit on
hopefully i get a little bit more of a reveal
for things that i don't know that are coming
since filming this so yay well that was iron
man 2. so i would say as a movie overall
there was a lot going on i feel like this
definitely served as a big setup movie for
the avengers that was really interesting there
was just so many different things going on
but i definitely can see how important this
movie is for iron man to be a part of the
avengers so that was interesting i did like the
additional characters that were in this movie
you got i know she's black widow eventually and
then nick fury and um i don't remember his name
that was really fun to see a bunch
of new characters i thought that
i then was such a fascinating character for me
because he technically didn't have many lines
but every time ivan was on screen i definitely
wanted more of his character because mickey
rourke did such a good job a lot of his moments
were just facial expressions and you could kind
of read him and see what he was going to do next
just by not saying anything which i thought was
really great um as an actor he just did such
a good job i just i wanted to see more of him
actually and the ending just was so abrupt with
him that also they didn't even use lasers on him
there's so many like things about this movie that
i felt like maybe aren't like plot holes but you
know when you're watching a scary movie and you're
like oh that's so dumb why did they do that like
i had a lot of moments watching this movie it did
seem really long i don't know if the first one the
first one was definitely the same around the same
length but for me the first one just felt way more
fast paced just like boom boom boom like getting
to the point and i felt like with this movie
i had a lot of slow moments and it was kind of
like a slow build and then at the end it was
just like boom boom boom boom boom done so that
was different um this yeah again this movie just
seemed like more of a setup movie i have heard
that iron man 3 is a lot of people's favorite
out of all out of the three iron man movies so
i am really excited to see that one and to see
kind of like how this movie sets up for the best
iron man movie um so that was interesting i feel
like tony stark was different in this movie i
mean obviously he was dying throughout the movie
but he just seemed a little different he seemed
definitely a little more carefree obviously his
confidence level i feel like seemed to be a little
lower as well so his spark was kind of gone but i
feel like he got it back towards the end same with
pepper pots i feel like she was just mad the whole
entire movie like that also kind of felt like
it came out of nowhere she was pissed off in the
whole movie and that and they kiss i definitely
would have loved to have seen more of like
maybe like i don't know like i don't know why
he was hiding the fact that he was dying from
her like obviously it adds conflict for the
characters obviously he wouldn't want to worry
her but i feel like he should trust her out of
everybody since she did kind of like save his
life in the last movie-ish so um i think it would
have been a little more interesting if she knew
in terms of action i loved the fight sequence
between um tony stark and his friend because
the one at the at his birthday party because
obviously that did set up you know their
heroic dynamic at the end in the finale but
i liked that one because it it was just more
interesting to watch i feel like than the last
action sequence um even though i didn't know how
they were going to fight off all of the drones it
seemed a little easy but like the fight between
them there was just so much buildup between the
two characters and uh i just thought that was
unique for a fight sequence um in comparison to
the ending sam rockwell's character i'm horrible
with names like remembering names from movies if
it's not like in your face the hammer uh was his
last name right he's an amazing actor by the way
like everything i see him in he just knocks it out
of the park and he played such an annoying [__]
in this movie that i'm like you did you did the
job um i know some people complain about there
being multiple villains in movies i know people
complained about it with uh spider-man 3 they
complained about it with the amazing spider-man 2.
i feel like this one also kind of had that
dynamic where there was kind of like multiple
villains and and they didn't really know
where the story was gonna go with the villains
um so i feel like that also got confusing like
who i don't know it's hard to do i feel like it's
hard to do a movie where there's two villains
and kind of balance it out this one i feel like
something was missing with it a little bit um but
i still really enjoy watching all the characters
perform together i feel like there were a lot of
scenes in this movie that felt really off the cuff
like a lot of the dialogue sometimes uh like
just felt kind of like it was ad-libbed or
or improved into the movie which i actually
really liked i i like when uh moments and movies
seem really like raw where they were like when he
was just like can i move this and she's like no
you can't move stuff like that i don't even know
if it was in the script it would be funny it was
like brilliant it was in the script but it
was just something on set that you improvise i
wouldn't be surprised but i love moments like that
because it it makes you forget you're watching a
movie it just looks like you're seeing two
people interact genuinely in a moment where
they have um it it's a special quality no
matter what is going on you cannot take
your eyes off that person every word they say
every gesture you're interested in do i have it
yeah i don't know overall uh this movie just made
me excited to see what is going to happen with all
the other characters and i think it was a great
introduction i did notice captain america's shield
right in it he was like oh oh yeah i've been
looking for that thanks i need it and it was just
a level for his project which was funny so and i
don't know if they're gonna have any more scenes
with the dad um tony stark's father because i feel
like that also didn't seem fleshed out enough like
i would love to see more of maybe flashbacks or
something of tony stark as a kid and then dynamic
between him and his father like that would be
a really that was a subject that i was hoping
they would explore more in the movie but um maybe
they explore it in another movie i feel like that
would explain tony stark's personality a little
bit more and would give a little more heart to
his character and like the moment when his
dad was like this is all for you i feel like
i would have felt like it was such a like
sweet moment i feel like i would have felt
it more if there was something in the beginning
between him and his father like as a flashback
when he was a kid i don't know but um i had
a lot of good moments though that i think
there just could have been more but then i feel
like also there could have been scenes that
could have been cut and it would have been fine i
don't know how to describe it because it was like
kind of a slower movie um for the first hour i
would say so anyway that was iron man 2. i hope
you enjoyed my reaction and my honest review on
the movie and uh yeah tune into the rest for phase
one i still have to watch thor iron man well i
guess iron man 3 isn't in i don't know what phase
that's in but i'm really excited to get to iron
man 3 so the rest are going to be thor captain
america and the avengers so i'm super excited
thanks again for watching hit that subscribe
button if you enjoyed hit that notification bell
if you uh want to know when i post the other ones
and uh yeah give it a like thanks for watching
this with me and i'll see you next week bye